so geht es nicht weiter mit unseren
schulen das ist das ergebnis einer neuen
studie
da kommen schüler aus unseren lern
betrieben so ist es leider oft und
beherrschen nicht die grammatik oder
können nicht richtig bruchrechnen der
grund ist einfach schlechter unterricht
es hat sich einiges geändert in unserer
gesellschaft seit den 50er jahren aber
im schulbetrieb scheint das noch nicht
angekommen zu sein monieren die
wissenschaftlerinnen der studie
was sich ändern muss jetzt in science
fiction aktive kopf schon zu meiner
schulzeit war klar hier muss sich etwas
ändern frontalunterricht zu rückständig
wie reitstall im raum der gehört einfach
in die mottenkiste schüler sind heute
ganz anders und schule neben müssen es
auch sein und auch heute wird es ja
schon häufig praktiziert projektwochen
schüler bereiten den unterricht vor und
so weiter das ist alles aber einzig ein
paar momente im unterrichtsalltag
frontalunterricht und jetzt haben wir es
amtlich frontalunterricht ist einfach
veraltet eine neue studie der potsdamer
professorin für empirische
unterrichtsforschung miriam fock und
anna donnerstag von der deutschen schule
akademie befindet live-unterricht weise
für vollkommen veraltet demnach ist
frontalunterricht nicht nur didaktisch
nicht mehr auf der höhe der zeit sondern
ist vor allem in einer veränderten
gesellschaft einfach nicht mehr
zeitgemäß oder ich würde mal sagen
unprofessionell die forscherin bemängeln
vor allem dass im frontalunterricht auf
die verschiedenen schüler und
schülerinnen
da haben sie mich geändert gar nicht
eingegangen werden kann
da gibt es jugendliche mit
migrationshintergrund oder mit einer
behinderung geflüchtet wie kinder die
sprachkenntnisse sind unterschiedlich
religion spielt eine rolle und und und
die instrumente und das finde ich die
richtige bezeichnung dafür wünsche mich
vorsintflutlich sitzenbleiben
versetzungen die nächst niedrigere
schulform förderschulen überspringen
einer stufe und so weiter nach pädagogik
klingt das alles nicht stattdessen haben
die wissenschaftlerinnen eine
verblüffend einfache lösung in
wissenschaftlerin sprachliches etwas
sperrig an differenziertes und
individualisiertes laden aber die idee
finde ich wirklich gut gruppen paddel
heißt es leichter verständlichen
bedeutet nichts anderes als die klasse
in verschiedenen gruppen einzuteilen und
dann entsprechend ihrer fähigkeiten für
unterrichten fortgeschritten erarbeiten
dann zum beispiel ein eigenes projekt
andere
übungsaufgaben und wieder andere werden
gezielt von der lehrerin oder dem lehrer
unterstützt ich kann nur sagen wir haben
es ja mal in mathe gemacht und am ende
hatten alle zu den gleichen
leistungsstand und ich fühle mich nicht
gut
es gibt also eine menge
verbesserungsbedarf sagt die studium was
sagt ihr
was wollt ihr in der schule verändern ab
damit in die kommentare und welche nicht
verpassen wollte in zukunft vom
man drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge
einfach draufklicken und vergesst nicht
wer danach einen auf die glocke zu geben
bis dann bleibt dran